la reunión entre la presidenta
taiwanessa Time Wayne y el presidente de
la cámara de representantes Kevin
mccarthy será mañana en la biblioteca
Ronald Reagan de California faltaba la
confirmación pero la reunión se daba por
descontada será el acto de mayor
enjundia política de su periplo de 10
días por Centroamérica para estrechar
sus relaciones con Belice y Guatemala
dos de los escasos aliados que conserva
junto a las dos paradas técnicas en
Estados Unidos china ha pedido a macarce
y que no repita los errores de su
predecesora se refiere a Nancy pelosi
taipei el pasado año provocó Las mayores
maniobras militares chinas en el
estrecho ha dicho Beijing que esa
reunión dañará los sentimientos del
pueblo chino enviará un mensaje erróneo
a los independentistas de la isla y
perjudicará las relaciones bilaterales
es seguro que la petición china será
ignorada las estancias de Chai en
Estados Unidos un país que por cierto no
reconoce a Taiwán han sido breves he
sabido que ha cancelado actos y rebajado
la presencia la prensa para no irritar
más de lo necesario a Beijing incluso la
sede de su reunión con mccarthy una
biblioteca parece Buscar ese perfil bajo
es probable que china responderá mañana
con ira pero muy improbable que se
repitan las maniobras militares del
pasado año el capítulo diario de
protestas chinas incluye también a
filipinas por permitir a Estados Unidos
que habrá cuatro nuevas bases militares
en su territorio dice Beijing que ese
acuerdo pondrá en peligro la paz y la
estabilidad y la estabilidad en la
región y ha pedido que los países de la
zona
reflexionen sobre lo que es apropiado y
lo que les beneficia